actor Danny Masterson was escorted out
of a Los Angeles courtroom in handcuffs
Wednesday guilty on two counts of rape
jurors were deadlocked on a third rape
charge
after a hung jury led to a mistrial last
year prosecutors tried Masterson again
accusing the actor of drugging and
raping the three women at his Hollywood
Hills home from 2001 to 2003. that's the
same time he was starring in a sitcom
That 70s Show the Church of Scientology
played a central role in the trial like
Masterson the three women were members
they testified that they reported
Masterson to Scientology officials but
because of his prominence at the church
we're told they were not raped feared
excommunication and discouraged from
going to the police the church strongly
denies blocking the victims or anyone
from cooperating with authorities